Why, why,
when it's time for us to join forces and start again from the beginning
Why
are you—  I'm going to the
Zeros kept their promise I
can't do anything that day I can't do that I
think it's bad
[music]
I want you to
understand what it means to be bad  I want something like
that, have
you ever thought about it? (B
) Have you ever thought about
how the people around you work
?  It's gone It's all about not being able to be free Have you ever
thought about that kind of anxiety of
everyone?  Separately say, I want
you to
come, write the feelings of the person who supports you,
and 5 will
imitate you and say goodbye
[music]
zero ii won't laugh at
me  It's the same as not living
[music]